[Música]
pois é pessoal
se tivesse sido acesa ea fazer uma
pergunta incrível
quem tem menos de 30 anos e aí a pessoa
sabe a levar a levantar a mão e eu já vi
que vocês levantaram a mão apesar de não
está enxergando quase nada mas quem tem
menos de 30 anos levanta a mão bem
rápido sabe por quê
porque se sente jovem nesse momento da
palestra todos os demais ficaram em
pânico porque nessa hora eles falam
assim ele vai continuar
ele vai perguntar novamente eu queria
perguntar quem é jovem levanta a mão
portanto a gente está precisando fazer
aqui uma terapia de grupo que vocês não
entendem nada do que era jovem
quem tem menos de 30 anos de idade não
sabe de algumas histórias mas há 30 anos
atrás
uma família composta unicamente de um
homem uma mulher e os seus filhos
cabendo um homem sustento da família ea
mulher a educação dos filhos e aos
filhos
a bagunça há 30 anos atrás você poderia
encontrar uma família com muitos irmãos
quem tem mais de 30 anos certamente já
percebeu que os seus filhos têm mais
tios do que irmãos
nós tínhamos irmão se você nasceu nessa
família
você tinha muitos irmãos provavelmente
você percebeu não dá pra exercer
individualidade só tinha um banheiro em
casa só tinha uma televisão você nasceu
provavelmente numa época onde a gente só
ganhava presente em duas ocasiões você
já tá falando
eram duas ocasiões o natal e aniversário
do natal era atrelado à performance o
que leva algumas pessoas a platéia xxi
como eu nasceu no dia 24 de dezembro
provavelmente só tinha uma chance e é
incrível porque nesse período a gente
tendo apenas uma chance você começou a
ser público
mário e nessa época você começou a
prender gingou e começou a pensar em
fazer campanhas publicitárias
provavelmente você naquele natal fez
como eu você cuidou da casa você lavar o
banheiro você passou a ser a polyphony
naquele quintal de caquinhos você fez
uma campanha publicitária incrível você
chegou e falou assim papai neste natal
não esqueça da minha tem muita gente com
mais de 30 anos aqui a gente já pode
perceber por que seu pai foi como o meu
o seu pai fez uma coisa incrível ele foi
numa loja de departamento fez um carnê
de 30 prestações e ele comprou uma caloi
para os quatro filhos
você ficou incrivelmente obcecado por
aquela caloi falou 'não eu vou começar a
trabalhar mais cedo e eu vou começar a
trabalhar mais cedo porque eu preciso da
minha caloi
aliás eu não quero só calor eu quero meu
chute é o que é uma coca-cola quero
beber crush eu quero meu 3 nenhum eu
preciso exercer a minha individualidade
e eu quero um quarto só pra mim e você é
incrivelmente pensou eu preciso
trabalhar você começou a sonhar e você
sonhou que com 18 anos provavelmente
você tiraria carta não cnh e você sonhou
com aquele carro aquele fiat 147
você queria muito ter um carro só pra
você você queria também ter um quarto só
para você com 34 irmãos impossível isso
acontecer você descobriu eu já sei o que
eu faço começa a trabalhar cedo lá perto
dos seus 22 23 anos de idade você já
conseguia alugar um apartamento e aí
vocês no boca vou fazer melhor que meu
pai você alugou um apartamento com dois
dormitórios com dois banheiros duas
televisões uma na sala uma no quarto
se você fez isso você provavelmente
colocou uma geladeira colocou o fogão e
depois uma cama e com essa estrutura
você já estava pronto para
casar e caso descobriu assim o trauma da
tua vida você nunca teria um quarto só
para você e você começou a pensar meu
deus o que eu devo fazer
eu preciso mudar essas coisas eu vou
fazer diferente eu vou fazer o que nunca
fizeram
o meu filho não vai ter esse problema eu
vou ter menos filhos que meus pais eu
não vou ter muito filho vou ter só dois
e aí meu filho vai ter tudo que eu não
tive
e só vai começar a trabalhar quando tem
muita gente que nasceu nesse período bom
é importante a gente pensar numa coisa
houve mudanças nos últimos 30 anos e não
foi só educacional
nós tivemos mudanças importantes eu
gostaria de mostrar pra vocês uma
mudança esse quadro provavelmente fez
parte da sua vida você aprendeu a dead
desvendar os mistérios da democracia
brasileira
você percebeu que lá embaixo no quadro
você encontra milhões de pessoas com
menos de 15 anos de idade e à medida que
vai passando o tempo mais idade vai
somando a pessoa incrivelmente vai
diminuindo o número de pessoas e por uma
razão simples as pessoas morrem
você não percebeu isso de cara porque
você está vendo só três faixas aí e você
está percebendo três faixas não entende
por que dividiu em três faixas por que
que só está sendo colocada dessa forma
que coisa arbitrária e você agora vai
dar sentido à raridade mais elevada
aquela idade da terceira idade a
primeira idade é a realidade que as
crianças existem até os 15 anos
a segunda idade é a idade de quem
sustenta essa bagaça toda ea última
idade injustamente não pode ser colocada
senão como terceira idade você
provavelmente acostumou a pensar em
algumas faixas
não se espera nos dias de hoje inclusive
que uma criança com até 15 anos de idade
de alguma maneira contribuir
para a sociedade eu não estou falando de
previdência de campo falando de gerar
valor para a sociedade você não espera
isso de uma pessoa até 15 anos até
porque ela está informação
você também não espera que a pessoa com
mais de 65 anos tenha que contribuir
também gerar valor é quase uma injustiça
na verdade você espera que quem
contribua são as duas partes do meio e
essas duas faixas você fala mas se você
está vendo duas faixas só tô vendo uma
bomba
não são duas porque durante esses
últimos 30 anos nós também aprendemos a
dividir a faixa em tipo de contribuição
ea gente estabeleceu que até os 25 anos
o jovem não contribui com muito valor
afinal de contas ele ainda está
terminando a formação afinal de contas
ele ainda está estabelecendo alguns o
seu espaço no mundo então não tem muita
contribuição o que diminui ainda mais à
parte quem realmente faz a contribuição
plena essa turma e após os 25 anos se
você está com 24 anos nesse momento você
já está começando a ficar um pouco em
pânico porque você começa a pensar está
chegando a hora
quem já passou de 25 falando eu sabia
que isso ia acontecer e quem tem filhos
com mais de 25 anos fala é será que ele
está vendo essa platéia palestra ele
devia estar contribuindo bom você viu
esse quadro mas na verdade esse quadro é
de 30 anos atrás e ele já não representa
a verdade nesses últimos 30 anos a gente
começou a descobrir um negócio incrível
eu vou ter menos filhos meus pais que de
alguma maneira parece que filho custa
caro ea gente começa a pensar será que
eu quero dá tudo que meu filho será que
se eu tiver muitos filhos vai dar tudo
certo
não a gente começou a ter menos filhos
ea gente descobrir uma coisa incrível
quanto menos filhos mais se vive
porque filho pode matar repare bem que o
gráfico mudou nesses últimos 30 anos a
gente está vendo que esse gráfico mudou
impressionantemente a repente as faixas
ficarão fora de hora
a faixa se mudarem a gente começou a
reparar que não tem gente morrendo lá na
ponta
era um pouquinho como não tem gente na
porta e você se lembra era he é verdade
alguma coisa aconteceu há 30 anos atrás
a gente falava com muita segurança eu
vou até os 65 que vier a mais é tá vendo
que seja até a frase está prontinho
só que de uma forma incrível nesses
últimos 30 anos a ciência avançou a
medicina avançou a sociedade ficou mais
consciente a comida piorou um pouco mas
a gente está aprendendo a não comer tudo
ea gente descobrir o seguinte hoje eu
não falo mais eu vou até os 65
hoje eu falo eu vou até os 80
e você sabe disso porque provavelmente
você está de olho em quem está morrendo
toda vez que alguém morre se quer saber
duas coisas você fica incrivelmente
eficiente de duas coisas que a pessoa
tem e você pergunta pessoa morre eu
quero saber de duas coisas e você está
pensando como é que ele sabe por que eu
estou lendo o pensamento de vocês como
diria alguém estou lendo você quer saber
do que morreu
e quantos anos tinha é incrível né
parece pnl isso aqui mas olha só que
absurdo você quer saber do que morreu
porque por um único motivo você quer
trocar de fila ea idade
a idade é impressionante você quer saber
a idade porque você quer fazer o
benchmark pessoal de modo que hoje se eu
digo pra você fulano de tal morreu aos
65 anos você fica chateado
dói o coração você começa a pensar e
falar algumas coisas do tipo
nossa ele morreu tão não ninguém é novo
com 65 anos de idade gente já tem uso
quem falou o jovem também não é bem
assim pode ser jovial mas não é novo mas
você pode pensar uma coisa melhor
nossa ele morreu tão fedo morreu antes
do que você esperava morrer um pouquinho
você fala nossa é muito pouco parece que
tinha mais para dar
só que se eu digo pra você que é fulano
de tal morreu 85 anos
você também se sente até uma paz do
coração não sente
não é isso que dá você fica bem não
viveu pelo menos não interessa morreu
faz parte da vida
você tá tranquilo com a idade de 80 anos
e não prestou atenção há 30 anos atrás
foi escrito estatuto do idoso
estabelecendo que 12 idosos a partir de
60 anos passado 30 anos hoje a gente não
pensa mais que vai até os 65 resto é
lucro
você pensa que vai 80 eo resto é lucro
em 30 anos subiu 15 anos a expectativa
de vida e é nesse momento que a palestra
fica mais densa fica mais pesada você
começa a pensar o que vai acontecer
você tem exatos 40 ou 50 anos você
percebe nesse momento que se era 65 e
hoje 80 daqui 30 anos você ainda está
vivo e daqui 30 anos esse número 95
se você tem menos de 30 anos então se
está preparado para descobrir a 14ª
razão pra você embora porque nesse
momento quem tem menos de 30 anos está
pensando
era aí daqui 30 eu tenho 60 já está
falando 95 cabe mais 30 isso muda tudo a
carreira sua não é mais uma carreira de
30 anos nem uma carreira de 35 nem de 50
quem tem menos de 30 anos têm que
começar a repensar a vida quem tem mais
de 30 anos e é casado deve pensar mais
ainda e se por acaso alguém noivo ou
noiva pode estar com a sua chance de
vida agora é sério a gente está
percebendo uma mudança na natureza uma
mudança na sociedade sabe o que acontece
todo mundo que é casado conhece na saúde
e na doença na riqueza e na pobreza na
alegria ou na tristeza até
e se não morrer você tem que repensar
tudo na sua vida carreira agora tem 70
anos e está preocupado com previdência
reparar bem isso mudou nós estamos
falando agora de um outro movimento e
esse movimento que eu quero chamar a
atenção primeiro nós estamos com faixas
diferentes hoje você espera se em
contribuição de quem tem até 75 anos
eles estão participando do mercado
não necessariamente na clt mas eles
estão participando no mercado muito você
também espera que o jovem contribua só
que tem uma coisa esse recado é para
quem tem menos de 30 anos e espera que
ele contribuem de alguma maneira nós
mudamos esse negócio porque a gente
começou a dizer que o jovem não precisa
contribuir totalmente até os 25 anos
isso é um problema porque nós criamos um
novo comportamento e reparem bem o que
vai acontecer se você tem menos de 30
anos você está bem no meio disso aí e
quem vai estar sustentando todo esse
negócio é você
a questão é o jovem não está entrando no
jogo então vou deixar umas coisas para
você nós temos algumas ações que estão
determinando a nossa vida nós somos mais
questionadores nós questionamos porque a
gente quer buscar informações a gente
quer repertório nós queremos expor as
nossas expectativas nós estamos fazendo
isso nas redes sociais isso porque a
gente pode apresentar propostas pode
apresentar idéias e todo mundo está
focado em resultados até aqui tá tudo
bem todo mundo acredita que é isso mas
eu queria dizer uma coisa pra vocês
o ser humano só busca um resultado que é
reconhecimento reconhecimento é aquele
que quando a criança é um presente um
brinquedo é um passeio quando você é
jovem entrar numa faculdade sair de uma
faculdade arrumar emprego mas o resto da
vida você tem outras conquistas para
fazer o que eu tô vendo aqui a gente
está se tornando preguiçoso com os
questionamentos
a gente questiona não mais para ter
informação porque ela está no smartphone
ela está disponível está acessível não
quero mais ter informação os
elas não estão mais lendo nada estão
vendo só post poucos pouquíssimos jovens
ficam um dia inteiro ouvindo informação
como vocês viram aqui muito poucos jogos
estão realmente atento
eles estão só olhando os pontos disse eu
tô falando jovem para todos os jovens
que estão aqui de todas as idades
na verdade a gente questiona para ter o
resultado você não gera pensamento
crítico nós estamos jogando fora o
pensamento crítico a gente começou a
viver uma vida de indiferença tanto fez
quanto tanto faz eu não tô nem aí não é
comigo ou pagam lá não é comigo as
coisas não estão acontecendo para mim
afetar eu não tô nem aí tudo que está
acontecendo não é comigo não faço parte
é ótimo se não faz parte mas você vai
estar vivo para ver o que vai acontecer
o jovem está ficando omisso e eu falo
para jovens de todas as gerações
a gente tá ficando omisso e você não
sabe o perigo que isso causa quando a
gente está omisso a gente fica
indisposto da indisposição a gente fica
desmotivado da desmotivação a gente fica
frustrado da restauração vem a
indignação
talvez você passou o dia hoje ouvindo
várias coisas vários pensamentos várias
histórias
eu queria deixar um último pensamento
para você a gente está muito ligado num
negócio de fazer o que ama porque daí
não tem que trabalhar mais isso é uma
verdade errada
certa vez um outro pede também falou e
teve um cara chamado bem rodovias que
ele falou uma coisa incrível ele foram
mais ou menos assim à conclusão que as
pessoas chegam é que se você fizer o que
ama você será bem sucedido isso pode até
ser verdade mas eu garanto pra você
se você for bem sucedido você vai amar o
que faz porque na verdade o ser humano
quer ver bem sucedido e só tem uma forma
para ser bem sucedido
você quer ser bem sucedido seja incrível
naquilo que você está fazendo qualquer
atividade
você foi convidado para várias
atividades hoje aqui pois eu te convido
então a ser incrível seja [ __ ] naquilo
que você faz que você vai ser uma pessoa
bem sucedida e se você for bem sucedido
você vai amar o que faz muito obrigado
pessoal
[Aplausos]